when you think about let's take ethereum
you mentioned earlier that some people
would say you know ethereum is a scam
can you articulate why some people think
that and then how do you think about
ethereum do you think it is a scam do
you think that it's uh not a scam like
just walk me through kind of your
evaluation of the folks who say that and
then like how you think about it
yeah that's a great question um i think
that you know ethereum
i've been a very loud critic of ethereum
for many years
i've also
you know put money into it here fairly
like very early in ethereum's lifetime
uh i think you can do both
and and it's funny to me that some
people can seem to be able to do that
you know like
critique something but also see the
positive side of it um but anyways um
i definitely don't view ethereum as a
scam i think funeral will have uh issues
going forward because i think it's going
to have a lot of competition i think
ethereum is kind of trying to
[Music]
both like be a very decentralized thing
uh but also it's not extremely
decentralized so it's kind of in a you
know between a heart between a rock and
a hard place meanwhile a lot of other
platforms are just optimizing for user
experience because again
uh you know i think something like nfcs
doesn't doesn't even matter if it's
decentralized or not so a lot of these
platforms are like saying okay
we're just going to optimize for speed
and for low fees and for easy ease of
use
and
we'll be more flexible so you know when
when the market shows uh the interest in
new things we'll be able to adjust for
that very quickly and extremely we'll
have in my opinion a hard time competing
because it's trying to be decentralized
while
the market in my opinion doesn't care a
lot about the centralization so i think
that will be a challenge for ethereum uh
that being said i don't think it's a
scam i think a lot of people have
multiple reasons why they call it the
scam one of the popular ones
is the pre-mine thing so what people
used to call pre-mine back in you know
when ethereum launched in 2015 or
whatever it was
um people used to
used to use the word pre-mine to
describe uh basically you know
basically a cap table that's what it is
like you like when you start a company
you're gonna have a cap table the early
investors and the founders are gonna get
you know some equity in the company
because otherwise why would you do it
and and that's completely normal when it
comes to companies but for some reason
when it comes to ethereum people view it
as a scam
um
and i think i think that's
that's a problematic view like one i
think i you know i'm i'm a capitalist i
believe that you know founders and early
investors should be
uh
rewarded for the risk they take so i i
don't i don't view the idea of free mind
as a problem it can be a problem if if
you think that ethereum is going to be
the global money then you might say well
you should have two people that have
seventy percent of the supply whatever
but uh i don't view service money i view
it as a platform for applications
and and it's totally reasonable for
early founders and early investors to
capture some of that value i think
that's totally fine so i don't view that
as a scam i think it's
it's also a very bad argument because
the type of people who are coming back
coming into you know crypto bitcoin
ethereum whatever it is and they're
looking at those arguments they're
looking at people saying well you should
invest in if because it had a pre mine
those people are just thinking well i
invested in amazon and amazon had pre
mine
so that's just a bad argument i don't
care
as an investor i know they're not the
first one into a theory you might
understand that but i see the growth
potential so i still want to invest so
it's just a bad argument it doesn't talk
you know it doesn't talk the lang
doesn't speak the language of the people
who are
considering investing into ethereum so
it's a bad argument that might lead
people to take the the you know the the
path you don't want them to take
um
i see that a lot by the way with the
so-called toxic bitcoin maximalist camp
like they they say a lot of things that
are technically true
but they end up arguing for the opposite
uh you know for the opposite position
because
the arguments they make just don't speak
the language of the people who are
asking the questions so that's one the
pre-mine is one big reason a lot another
big reason is you know people say well
if you've changed what it is like it
promised to be one thing and over time
it's changed what it's doing
and and that's like you know that's what
a lot of successful companies do it's
totally reasonable you try something it
doesn't work or maybe
you realize there's no market demand so
you're trying something else
i don't view that as a problem at all
definitely it's not a scam
so yeah i wouldn't use the word scam to
describe ethereum i'm not particularly
bullish on ethereum at all like you know
people confuse that very often they say
oh woody said it's not a scam so he's
trying to show us ethereum i'm really
not i just i'm just thinking
i'm not particularly bullish on ethereum
at all
i just think that you know people if
you're going to call everything a scam
you're just going to have a very hard
time to get to you have people to see
your side
because you know someone shows up and
they ask you a question you call them a
scammer then they're not going to talk
to you again it's over
how do you how do you talk to someone if
they're just calling you a scammer an
idiot talk so i just think we need to
stop this behavior yeah talk to me about
the um ability for you to be critical of
ethereum but you said that you also
bought ether very early on so basically
you financially held it but you were
also critiquing it and
you know on the internet that's not
allowed right obviously you can't you
can't do both things so talk a little
bit about like why why do both and
why do you
buy it even though you're critiquing it
or why do you critique something that
you're holding
right so my uh so okay first of all
probably most of my critique of ethereum
was in points in time that i didn't hold
it
um but but i did also definitely have uh
criticism about it um
when i did hold some
and for me you know for me
kind of my style has been
that this is how i learn you know i i
i first i research those things myself i
look into them i i see things that i
like i see things that i don't like
um you know i recognize where i might
see some growth
but then i talk a lot about the things
that i don't like because i want you
know i kind of want people to change my
mind
you know and
and that seems to
you you you kind of get to attract a lot
of smart people who will
um
you know correct you where you're wrong
and
or support what you think so i find it
for me it's just a you know it's a style
thing right it helps me
uh learn about those things
um and i think i think
you know i think it's very reasonable if
you want to
invest in something you want to know
what what the benefits are but also you
want to know what the issues are i think
it's very reasonable
um it's okay to talk about those things
uh probably everything in the crypto
space has a lot of drawbacks even
bitcoin
i hope i don't get cancelled for this
but even bitcoin has some issues so what
do you think are the drawbacks of
bitcoin
so we talked about the privacy thing
um
i think that's a big one
i think that um
you know bitcoin very early on even like
people like you know like hal finney and
probably satoshi talked uh you know in
the bitcoin talk forums about how it's
very likely that you know custody of
bitcoin will centralize over time uh
they they saw that back in
in 2010 and where's i think we're seeing
that happening today
uh for real where a lot of you know
bitcoins are kind of centralizing in in
in those bitcoin banks
and that might be fine i'm not saying
that's necessarily bad uh but it
definitely you know it changes the
dynamics and it's it's not definitely
it's necessarily what a lot of people
expected that would happen
um
and and it changes the kind of the power
dynamics
so yes the best coin is very
decentralized um
but it's not perfect you know i i it's
very hard for me to imagine that people
uh
if if you know if the future we believe
in where everyone will own bitcoin in
the future
um is true it's very hard for me to
imagine that people will all you know
manage their own keys
and have you know bitcoin in
self-custody i i doubt that would be the
case because
it's not really built for that in my
opinion
um we'll see who knows
but you know i think a lot of it is not
what people expect it to be which could
be fine i mean i still i'm still
extremely bullish on bitcoin i think
it's uh it has a lot of room to grow
but
you know it's we we keep learning how
those things are not what we expect
all the time what's up guys bang bang
your boy pomp thanks so much for
watching the best business show our goal
is to make this the largest most
actionable business show in the world
and to do that we need your help we've
partnered with sofi as our exclusive
sponsor because they have a piece of
software that we think will help you
take the information that we share on a
daily basis and make it actionable we
want every single person to pursue and
achieve financial security and financial
freedom in order to do that you gotta
act and sofi allows you to do it so you
can go to sofi.com today you can open up
an account and when you open up an
account you can invest in all sorts of
different types of assets etfs
individual stocks ipos bitcoin
cryptocurrencies they even have an
automated investing function if you want
to invest sofi can help you they've got
a couple of different offers that you
can benefit from the first open an
invest account and they'll give you up
to a thousand bucks for free kind of a
no-brainer second is if you go on and
you buy one of the cryptocurrencies that
they offer they'll go ahead and they'll
give you ten dollars of bitcoin for free
and third some of you are saying i
already have a brokerage account i
already have an account somewhere else
right now you can get up to five
thousand dollars for transferring your
account that's right sofa doesn't care
where your current account is but if you
transfer it from that place to sofi
they'll pay you up to five thousand
dollars for doing it why wouldn't you do
it it's up to five thousand dollars for
free head on over to sofi.com today to
get started and come back tomorrow and
watch more of the best business show
together we're gonna build the biggest
show in the world
[Music]